quand vous allez ça va bien j'espère moi
ça va plutôt pas mal à regarder
aujourd'hui on va se parler de ce smart
je vous tourne pas le dos je prends les
produits de r on va se parler de ce
smartphone là qui est normalement dans
cette boîte et qui est à ma main dans ma
poche depuis un petit moment c'est
l'iphone 12 pro il iphone 12 pro je
l'utilisé depuis quelques jours et puis
vous assurer que j'ai plein de choses à
vous raconter le suis parce que l'iphone
12 pro il fait plein de jolies promesses
on effectivement dans le très haut de
gamme chez apple
appelant à élargir sa gamme on a plein
d'iphone cette année il va moins quatre
iphones annoncé pts 2e semestre 2020 il
y aussi un iphone et ce deuxième version
qui est sorti il ya quelques mois donc
cette année ya beaucoup d'iphone et je
crois que c'est la première année où il
y en autant d'iphone sortie donc ça
c'est plutôt bien et ça ravira tous les
fans d'apple et tous les fans des iphone
sauf que cet iphone 12
il est très cool il se situe à mi chemin
entre l'iphone 12 et l'iphone 12 prend
max dont on parlera prochainement que ce
soir iphone 12 ou l'iphone 12 promax et
ya également l'iphone 12 min on en
parlera également plus tard donc vous
invite dès maintenant à venir vous
abonner ce n'est pas déjà le cas comme
ça vous serez tous des comparer à des
prochains iphone et des prochains
smartphones et les prochains tests en
règle générale et ça c'est très très
cool alors aujourd'hui on va se
recentrer sur l'iphone 12 promax à
l'iphone os promax il est vraiment très
intéressant c'est vraiment un très très
beau smartphone on parle de nombreux
points que ce soit au niveau de l'écran
le duo l'expérience globale la photo il
ya beaucoup de choses à dire dessus il
ya aussi des choses que j'aime un petit
peu moins et qui viennent me gênait sur
iphone je vais tous vous détailler je
vais tout vous expliquer rester bien
jusqu'à la fin pour tout savoir et vous
allez voir dans l'ensemble moi j'aime
beaucoup et c'est vraiment un très joli
produit mais à quelques petits trucs
quand même quelques petits trucs
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec clip vous
venir protéger vos iphone je vous
explique le coût mensuel pour venir
assurer un iphone 12
c'est 6 euros 99 et pour cette somme
vous allez l'assurer contre les dommages
et contre le vol puisque je ne sais pas
si vous connaissez je n'ai déjà parlé
dans une précédente vidéo c'est une
assurance 100% digitale tout se fait au
travers de l'application que ce soit
l'inscription que ce soit la gestion de
vos sinistre parce que oui c'est un des
gros avantages de cette assurance vous
devenez l'activé que lorsque vous en
avez besoin vous n'avez l'obligation de
n'assurer vos smartphones que trois mois
parmi les douze mois
le reste du temps vous pouvez ne pas
l'assurer et c'est l'intérêt de cette
nouvelle assurance c'est à dire que je
me dis qu'en ce moment il est vrai parce
que je suis dans un confinement ce qui
est actuellement des confiné on n'a pas
nécessairement besoin de venir assuré
france maarten parce qu'on ne va pas
forcément sortir mais par contre vous
partez sur un déplacement professionnel
je ne sais où vous dites je crains que
ce soit pour la casse que ce soit pour
le vol est bien avant de partir je viens
activé mon assurance et je suis protégé
pour toute la période
et lorsque je rentre je désactive
l'assurance ce qui fait que je ne paye
lorsque j'en ai réellement besoin et ça
c'est vraiment bien que vous êtes
couvert notamment pour un vol par an et
pour deux casses par an et si les casses
et sachez qu'il ya plus de 180 centre
agréé en france
mounir le faire réparer la plupart du
temps en moins de 24 heures et si ça
prend un peu plus de temps eh bien vous
prêtera un smartphone de valeur
équivalente
je vous ai fait une vidéo complète pour
vous expliquer vous présentez clics vous
avez le lien en bas d'un description et
vous avez également le lien pour venir
découvrir et utiliser klink et profiter
de 20% de réduction sur votre assurance
en cliquant sur le lien dans la
description vous pouvez venir bien
évidemment assurer vos smartphones mais
tous vos objets numériques que ce soit
une tablette que ce soit un ordinateur
une non collecté une console et même un
vélo
donc ça c'est très bien une fois de plus
vous avez tous les liens en bas dans la
description
l'iphone 12 pro succède à l'iphone os
pro alors mais si c'est pas l'iphone ans
procès iphone on se promenait avec ce
que je prends pour venir illustrer la
différence
la vraie grosse différence que vous
allez retrouver c'est ici notamment au
niveau de l'iphone ans pro les forces
pro mac vous aviez des bords incurvés
cette fois ci cette année on a débord
totalement plat ça change un peu le
design ça change un peu la prise en main
on ait une prise en main qui est quand
même malgré tout bonne on sent un peu
plus les angles qu'on le sente et sur
les autres modèles de l'année dernière
c'est un peu différent mais dans
l'absolu ça change pas grand chose
on garde les mêmes positions de boutons
sur les côtés bien évidemment on garde
toujours un peu la même idée de toute
façon apple ne révolutionne pas ses
designs une fois de plus on reste
vraiment dans la même chose je vous le
dis si celle max c'est la raison pour
laquelle à voyez il est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus grands
on a un dôme at celle céramique chine et
celle en chili vraiment intéressant
pourquoi il ya parce qu'en fait apple va
venir encore plus renforcer la
résistance de ses produits ce sont en
fait des cristaux de céramique
nanométrique qui le rendent encore plus
résistant aux chutes et ça c'est quand
même plutôt bien dans l'idée un
smartphone qui pèse 189 g qui est une
certification ip68 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière vous pouvez l'immerger à
6 mètres pendant 30 minutes si vous le
souhaitez c'est toute une structure qui
est en acier inoxydable chirurgicale
c'est vrai qu'on a une sensation qui est
quand même différente en termes de prise
en main j'arrive pas à vous dire lequel
je préfère entre l'arrondi ou le bord
comme ça un peu plus carré rectangulaire
je trouve cet écran vraiment beau
vraiment très très très bien maîtrisée
de la part d'apple écran super retina
xdr 6,1 pouces qui est plus grand que ce
qu'on avait l'année dernière sur
l'iphone 11 pro 9 à l'écran de 5,8
pouces la saint silain pousse toujours
du oled est surtout un écran qui est
extrêmement lumineux il peut monter
jusqu'à 1200 need un écran hd r10 plus
dolby vision trou tonnes on a une gamme
de couleurs p3 enfin j'ai vous passez
côté vraiment trop technique honda à
l'écran qui est super bien calibré
vraiment bien maîtrisée mois la dernière
apple avait vraiment surpris avec son os
mac book pro 16 pouces est ce qu'il
avait vraiment surpris c'est pas sur toi
taille de l'écran passer du 15 pouces
chaussées school c'était surtout
l'expérience sonore de fait d'avoir
quelque chose d'extrêmement immersif et
de très larges et il faut vraiment
l'écouter pour s'en rendre compte
vraiment et ça je vous invite à le faire
un jour si vous en avez l'occasion pas
forcément dans un magasin parce que moi
que le bruit environnant c'est peut être
un petit peu compliqué vous écouter un
son qui est un petit peu loin et il
vient de votre ordinateur qui est juste
devant vous et vous en rendez pas compte
tout cas très bluffant et j'ai trouvé un
peu la même expérience avec ses iphone
12 pro et ça m'a vraiment plu je tiens
mon iphone à la main ça me ramène le
sont un peu sur le devant et tenant
comme ça avec ma main j'avais
l'impression par moments que le son
arrivée de par là bas alors que l'iphone
est là et ça s'est vraiment bien on a
une vraie belle spatialisation au niveau
du son avec cet iphone la qualité est là
l'expérience est bonne alors forcément
vous comprendrez que là on a un
emplacement sur un haut parleur soit
côté ici donc ne sont pas plus par là
bas en train de directivité là il est en
façade on compare plus de vent mais je
puis vous assurer qu'on a malgré tout
sensation d'immersion un son qui est
large
un spectre qui est beau qui est bien
maîtrisé une fois de plus de la part
d'apple
donc pour contenus multimédia pour des
jeux or casque or écouteurs horaires
potes
eh bien on a vraiment quelque chose qui
est vraiment hyper agréable à utiliser
et une vraie bonne sensation d'immersion
au cndp et jody et c'est un très très
gros point positif
et si vous voulez aller plus loin vous
branchez vos et repose ou erp aux pros
bluetooth 5.0 côté performances j'ai pas
grand chose à vous dire on a ici un
nouvelle puce de apple c'est la puce à
bionic elle marche merveilleusement bien
vous n'avez pas de ralentissement pour
faire tourner tous vos jeux vos
applications du multitâche si vous
souhaitez pourquoi pas du multitâche le
votre iphone 12 pro réagira toujours
très bien vous accompagnera toujours
bien y'a pas de ralentissement ya rien
et c'est vraiment c'est aussi
intéressant chez apple s'il voulait
c'est que vous êtes toute la partie
logicielle qu'il parfaitement adapté à
la partie matérielle eyeos les iphone
sont des puces fabriquées par apple
on a un smartphone où tout est optimisé
et harmonisée ça ne peut que bien marché
et une fois de plus apple réussit
vraiment bien sa copie là dessus une
grosse nouveauté et non des moindres qui
est vraiment très intéressant c'est que
pour la première fois chez apple eh bien
on a un smartphone 5g je vous en ai déjà
parlé lorsque j'ai introduit ce
smartphone ya quelques temps premier
smartphone 5g d'apple qui va leur
garantir des positions assez énorme en
termes de ventes de smartphones je pense
avec ses iphone de 2020 vous cartonnez
dans le monde entier
2 par effectivement l'arrivée de la 5g
peut-être pas en france mais très
probablement en asie
aux usa on verra ça en début d'année
2021 mais malheureusement moi
aujourd'hui là où je suis eh bien il n'y
a pas de couverture 5g je n'ai pas
d'abonnement sage et donc je ne peux pas
tester la salle j'ai donc d'ailleurs
dites le moi vous d'ailleurs là où vous
êtes
est ce que vous avez acheté des dalles
et smartphone d'apple est ce que vous
avez la 5g je vais maintenant vous
parler d'autonomie et ça va introduire
la partie que j'aime un petit peu moins
qui me plaît un petit peu moins
au niveau de ce nouvel iphone je vous
explique déjà l'autonomie est très bonne
on garde comme on avait l'année dernière
une autonomie d'à peu près une journée
ni à deux jours si vous allez vraiment
cool
une journée si vous l'utilisez de façon
intensive vous leurs charges et le soir
très rapidement ça ça ira très très bien
maintenant il ya tout qui me dérange un
petit peu c'est que vous le voyez ici
vous avez des toutes petites boîtes
toute petite boîte tout mini je vous ai
déjà dit déjà expliqué que cette année
apple a fait le choix de ne pas mettre
son blog de charge 20 watts à
l'intérieur il faut venir
elle lâche t as pas et ça c'est vraiment
dommage et je le dis et je le redis
parce que autant les coudées iphone
n'augmentent pas vous avez ici votre
câble lightning pour venir recharger
c'est bien c'est pratique pourquoi pas
on reste sur les mêmes coûts de base que
les années précédentes c'est bien
j'imagine effectivement que cet iphone
coûte plus cher à fabriquer parce que
vous avez des nouveautés comme tous les
ans et même malgré tout on reste au même
prix mais en fait on en a un petit peu
moins on est un petit peu moins parce
que vous n'avez pas çà çà çà coûte 25
euros
je me dis une fois de plus pourquoi est
ce que pour 25 euros qui est le prix de
vente un prix de vente au consommateur
final en france avec la tva pourquoi est
ce que apple ne pourrez pas vous
intégrez ça directement dans la boîte
je sais pas comment ça leur coûte 1
peut-être 5 euros je sais rien je dis ça
vraiment au hasard il ajoute ça leur
coûte entre 5 et 10 euros
pourquoi est ce qu'ils ne voulaient
intègre pas dans la boîte quitte à
augmenter le prix ça me pose un problème
de ne pas avoir taxé soir le devoir
acheter en plus parce que pour toutes
les personnes qui arrivent chez apple et
qui n'ont pas ces accessoires là eh bien
ils vont devoir débourser de l'argent
pour la voir même si c'est un accessoire
qui va donc peut-être entre
17 dollars aux usa rien j'ai pas regardé
je vous laisse un petit peu au hasard
eh bien ça veut dire que vous prenez ces
fameux 17 $ vous les multipliez par les
millions ce que je pense mais des
millions et comme je le faisais c'est un
smartphone qui va beaucoup de vendre
parce qu'on arrive sur une bascule au
niveau de la 5g et bien ces paramètres
entraient quand même quelques millions
de plus dans les poches d'apple et je
trouve ça un petit peu rare au niveau de
tous les consommateurs qui vont
l'acheter et qui n'auront pas accessoire
ça me fait vraiment râler parce que une
fois de plus ça va ramener beaucoup
d'argent apple ça me dérange pas
qu'apple beaucoup d'argent bien
évidemment ça pose absolument aucun
problème mais ce qui me pose problème
c'est que ce soit au détriment de la
bourse des consommateurs qui eux par
contre vont devoir débourser un peu plus
d'argent pour pouvoir recharger leur
smartphone notre bonne condition que ça
c'est dommage
alors après apple afin tout très cool
cette année c'est qu'ils ont sortis cet
accessoire là cet accessoire là il est
vendu dans cette boîte là j'en ai tous
les côtés je sais ça s'appelle le
magsafe alors le magsafe c'est très cool
parce que ça vous permet d'utiliser
votre bloc de charge de 20 watts vous le
branchez dedans et vous allez pouvoir
venir recharger votre smartphone très
rapidement je le prends je positionne y
trouve sa place et il se recharge
rapidement ça chauffe ça vraiment bien
c'est très malin en plus ils ont proposé
des coques de protection aux appareils
qu'ils acceptent le magsafe donc c'est
plutôt malin et ça fonctionne mais donc
j'aime bien cet accessoire mais si vous
voulez le magsafe il vous coûtera à 45
euros plus les 25 euros vous êtes donc à
70 euros pour votre chargeur à induction
aujourd'hui chez apple c'est une somme
mais voilà voilà
et dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire côté photo apple
propose la même configuration que
l'année dernière vous avez un triptyque
de 12 mégapixels en grand-angle de 12
mégapixels que bref 1.6 en ultra
grand-angle et ouvre à f 2.4 un tel
objectif qui ouvre à f 2.0
et en plus de ça cette année on a le
droit à la caméra lidar qui planquaient
juste en dessous ici que vous servir
notamment pour le mode portrait mais
également pour la réalité augmentée
ça ça m'intéresse beaucoup parce que
apple maîtrise vraiment bien sa partie
photo c'était déjà le cas l'année
dernière ma c'est une fois de plus le
cas cette année je vous montre le
résultat des photos dans quelques
instants de jour comme de nuit
le résultat est vraiment extrêmement de
le fond on va capter plus de lumière
avec ce nouveau capteur principal avec
une ouverture qui va être un peu plus
faible que ce sera vraiment bien en
conditions de faible luminosité ça c'est
très très cool
maintenant il ya un truc un peu bizarre
mais c'est une fois de plus sans
parti-pris d'apple et c'est pas très
dérangeant et malgré tout je note c'est
qu'en fait vous avez la possibilité
lorsque vous venez faire vos photos aura
des jours montre je suis en x 2 et je
peux monter me rapprocher coucou c'est
moi je m'en jusqu'en x 10 et c'est un
choix qu'a fait apple etc à
sainte-thérèse
pourquoi parce que en fait là on voit
qu'on a beaucoup beaucoup de
constructeurs et c'est pas nouveau à ces
deux puis l'année dernière avec
l'arrivée des zoom périscopique et bien
il ya beaucoup de constructeurs qui
montre les muscles notamment samsung on
l'a vu en début d'année avec son space
zone jusqu'à fois sans y en a qui
restent au x 30 et qui le font très bien
y en a qui vont jusqu'au x 50 apple dit
ok nous rentre pas dans cette course là
on n'a pas envie de montrer qui est le
plus gros zoom on reste au x 10 mais par
contre nous faut dix il fonctionne bien
on va les vérifier ça il faut être plus
dans quelques instants
et c'est vraiment marrant qui n'est pas
pris le pape se dire ou le pl est de se
dire on va les lettres j'imagine que
apple travaille peut-être pour ses
projets futurs sur des zoom périscopique
j'aurais du mal à comprendre qu'à qui
n'hesite pas qui ne regarde pas mais
peut-être se distille ça peut paraître
assez logique que puisque avec un zoom x
59 x 100 avec le mac c'est en tout cas
qu'on puisse obtenir son zoom est bien
la qualité elle est pas là elle n'est
pas au rendez vous on a un effet un
petit peu what the fuck un peu rigolo
mais pas nécessairement exploitables ça
me semblait en tout cas la réponse
probable du manque d'intégration de
cette technologie sur les nouveaux
iphone peut-être l'année prochaine
peut-être les années après ou peut-être
jamais ou peut-être aurons-nous un sou
neuf fois 20 lors ce qu'ils estimeront
que le résultat sera suffisamment
intéressante pour tenir le
commercialiser apple va encore plus loin
cette année au niveau de la photo et de
la vidéo vous pouvez filmer jusqu'à en
4k à 60 images par secondes vous avez
votre vidéo avec le sdf pouvez activer
désactiver leur attention
il ya un petit truc à connaître si pour
vous seriez instagram comme moi vous
avec votre smartphone et qu'ensuite vous
l'importez directement d'instagram mais
il faut désactiver la vidéo hd air sont
quoi vous aurez l'image un peu
blanchâtre et qui ne fonctionnera pas
mais si par contre vous les quelque
chose qui marche vraiment bien et bien
vous le réactiver
vous allez pouvoir filmer ici en 10 bits
avec la technologie dolby vision qui
marchent merveilleusement bien parce que
oui apple a fait un truc de dingue cette
année sur ses iphone vous pouvez filmer
en 10 bits hdr dolby vision vous aller
capter beaucoup plus de couleurs en
rendu hyper qualitatif après la question
c'est avez vous réellement besoin de
filmer en 10 bits hdr peut-être
peut-être pas pouvait le désactiver si
vous ne souhaitez pas mais en tout cas
ce qui est dingue c'est le voir une fois
de plus la capacité de calcul de leurs
puces à 14 bionique de voir ce que cet
iphone est capable d'encaisser
si vous voulez faire la vidéo de très
bonne qualité pour du contenu sur
internet ou même faire des courts
métrages de films et rec qui le font et
bien vous pouvez utiliser son iphone
parce qu'il est vraiment d'une
excellente qualité au niveau de la vidéo
au niveau de l'audio par contre il vous
faudra quand même brancher un micro
externe pour avoir une meilleure source
mais pour l'image ça
c'est vraiment bien avec l'iphone ce qui
est impressionnant c'est vraiment la
stabilisation que vous avez un sens
c'est vraiment des gros gros gros gros
point fort des avenues dernière avec le
onze proches promax tu es assez ouf
et là c'est pareil avec le 12 trop c'est
complètement dingue pour l'ultra grand
temps il faut que je change a par contre
j'ai pas de stabilisation optique c'est
tout de suite beaucoup moins apprécié ça
bouge et ça c'est un peu dommage
et quand je filme je peux venir zoom et
tac en x 2 jusqu'en x 3 avec 7 stable à
c'est très bien et je trouve que c'est
vraiment extrêmement efficace et avec la
caméra selphy ça marche bien alors ce
que je reprochais que la caméra celle ci
c'est qu'on ait stabilisation
électronique
on n'a pas ce talent isation optique ce
qui fait que ça bouge légèrement et
surtout moi avec les tremblements c'est
un truc qui pardonne pas et ça c'est
vraiment typique mans pour moi parce que
sinon pour le commun des mortels je
pense que ça posera absolument aucun
problème il faut venir maintenant doit
stand où il vient avec nous je sais
qu'ils te plais bien ici mais rejoint
nous on a une émission à faire et arrête
de faire cette mauvaise tête ça ne
ressemble pas rencontré un petit test de
vidéos de nuit avec l'iphone sont le
principe serait pas mal à voir
après sur l'écran si c'est bien ou pas
parce que comme ça en tout cas c'est
bien mais surtout c'est très très stable
une fois de plus pour la vidéo à l'ultra
grand temps que par contre la nuit là on
y voit absolument rien la caméra lidar
vous servira pour la réalité augmentée
venir prendre des mesures au pta qui si
ma boîte je montre juste la tac tac tac
tac tac tac 13 cm un petit peu de
travers et en switch peut redescendre
voilà 17 cm la mesure comme ça et pas
complètement dingue mais en tout cas ce
n'est certes pas une chose très très
sympa si vous aimez en tout cas le
concept de réalité augmentée bien voyez
avec ce smartphone et la caméra lidar on
peut vraiment venir s'amuser on
permettra également de venir à optimiser
toutes vos photos en mode portrait ça
permettra d'aller plus vite pour la
photo de nuit parce que oui ici c'est
d'infrarouge donc pour toutes vos photos
de lui pour vos scènes de nuit ça va
venir déclenché beaucoup plus rapidement
et même lorsque voulait prendre
quelqu'un en photo la nuit en dehors
même du mode portrait ça fera un point
beaucoup plus vite ce sera beaucoup plus
réactif
alors moyenne un truc que j'aime bien
chez apple qui est tout bête ce qu'on va
pas venir sont embêtés au niveau des
modes au niveau de la photo par exemple
voyez vous avez un seul mode pas de mode
nuit vos smartphones est intelligent il
va venir s'adapter automatiquement à vos
conditions de luminosité et ça c'est
simple c'est bien moi j'étais assez
bluffé j'étais assez bluffé par la fois
lorsque je suis parti faire des photos
et notamment au niveau des photos de
nuit parce que je prenais mon iphone je
shootais dans la nuit je vous montre les
photos dans quelques instants vous allez
voir le rendu est bien je vois une scène
je vois une image à travers mon iphone
j'appuie sur le bouton je vois que bon
c'est la nuit s'est pas complètement
dingue
et là on même pas une seconde j'ai cette
image qui est complètement embellie
c'est assez bluffant
là on était à rennes en tournage pour ça
va cartonner avec amazon prix sur le
capteur principal ça fonctionne luttera
grand-angle et bien on voit une
différence bien évidemment de
colorimétrie très légèrement trop ultra
grand-angle et capteur principal c'est
un peu plus brut et bon rien de bien
surprenant là dessus on se rapproche a
été très bon avec le téléobjectif
on peut venir vous y voyez que des
consomme davantage hedayat traitement
logiciel ça vient un petit peu lisse et
c'est moins cali mais c'est aussi normal
rennes mais surprenant là dessus
toujours à rennes voyez lutte racontant
une petite différence par contre ça
reste quand même très très cali a malgré
tout y attention à ne pas trembler à
être bien stabilisé pour votre
ultra-grand-angle c'est un peu le ce
qu'il faut vraiment savoir mais sinon
dans l'absolu le résultat est quand même
plutôt bien et l'iphone 12 pro fait
vraiment des photos de bonne qualité
photo nue photo lui c'est vachement
intéressant la gestion de la lumière est
vraiment bonne
on voit bien un peu tous les côtés ça ça
va très très bien dès qu'on passe sur le
trac en tant que c'est un petit peu
moins terrible mais vous allez le voir
un peu plus loin l'appareil caméra
principale ça va
on se rapproche la qualité plutôt aller
sur tout ce qui est assez surprenant
c'est que moi je voyais beaucoup de
bruit à l'image est là il ya un vrai
traitement logiciel qui vous a réduit
tout le bruit on devine l'un vraiment
dans le ciel ce soir quel écran vous le
regardez si vous êtes sur un grand écran
vous le verrez peut-être sur un
smartphone peut être un petit peu moins
il ya vrai beau traitement logiciel qui
appliquaient là dessus par apple ça
c'est assez impressionnant et on le voit
en vrai en direct il croyait mort at on
appris la photo il convainc résultat on
est vraiment bluffé sur l' ultra
grand-angle tout de suite moins ça la
qualité pas terrible info tenue ultra
grand-angle je vous le déconseille
néanmoins l'amendement zoomer avec votre
thé l'objectif la qualité est là et dans
l'ensemble on sera vraiment très très
bien
le mode portrait le mode portrait assez
intéressante parce qu'une fois de plus
on a vraiment tout la capacité de calcul
de leurs puces à 14 bionique ça ne des
tours bien tous les côtés il ya
différents modes portrait qui font
vraiment bien la faire ça c'est pas tout
nouveau chez apple ça marche très très
bien on continue à rennes il pleut pour
des bâtiments ça marche bien
les photos sont vraiment de super bonne
qualité attention ne pas trop bien vous
rapprocher sans quoi vous perdre en
précision mais sera une fois de plus
c'est normal l'ultra grand angle un peu
moins précis mais fera l affaire pour
des bâtiments et malgré tout ça reste
quand même très qualitatif on a du wifi
6 on a du nfc avec notamment apple p
l'iphone 12 pro peut accueillir une
carte nano symplus une sim a
soudainement je t'aime beaucoup et je
trouverais modernité il ya toute une
réflexion à mener au niveau de la
configuration si vous souhaitez acheter
ce smartphone parce que oui si je
regarde bien ce smartphone si vous
l'achetez dans sa première configuration
de base
eh bien vous aurez 128 giga de stockage
vous avez également la possibilité de
monter jusqu'à 256 go de stockage ou
alors 512 giga de stockage ici non
extensible on est chez apple on
n'augmente pas la capacité de stockage
grâce à une carte microsd
on va uniquement acheter de l'espace
dans le club ça c'est une autre histoire
si je pars souvent version 128 go de
stockage je suis à 1159 euros et une
fois de plus je vous le dis sans ça il
faut le savoir si je passe sur la
version 256 giga de stockage je vais
rajouter 120 euros je suis à 1279 euros
et si je passe sur la version 512 gia de
stockage je suis à 1509 euros maintenant
la question oui de combien avez vous
besoin en termes de capacité de stockage
moi personnellement je vous montre ce
que j'utilise j'ai un iphone avec une
grosse capacité de stockage et je suis
loin de vraiment
toutes utilisées g54 saljic a utilisé
sur 512
autant dire je dédie ce pas grand chose
et si vous regardez sur toutes mes
applications
spotify netfix utilise un petit peu
parce que j'enregistre de la musique et
des films
sinon tout le reste voilà y'a pas grand
chose et est ce qu'il ya un vrai intérêt
aujourd'hui acheter 1 512 giga de
stockage honnêtement je suis pas sûr
j'ai tendance à penser que 512 il ya de
stockage pourra potentiellement vous
servir si vous faites de la vidéo si
vous faites beaucoup de vidéos si vous
tournez un court métrage un film vous
vous enregistrez plein de vidéos et
plein d'émissions là dessus mais en
dehors de ces usages là je suis pas
persuadé que vous ayez besoin de ça
regardez déjà là avec 128 giga du
stockage sur la version en 1159 euros et
bien ça fera très très bien faire est là
je vous parle vraiment d'un usage sur
plus d'un an alors cet iphone n'est pas
depuis plus d'un an mais j'avais avant
celui ci le 11 promax j'ai fait une
copie parfaite en une image parfaite
donc on est vraiment sur un usage de
plus donnant au niveau de ses iphones et
j'utilise depuis longtemps avec pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai choisi moi d'utiliser en
téléphone personnel un iphone tout
simplement pour mes story instagram pour
ma vidéo sur instagram parce que c'est
un peu le défaut qu'on peut retrouver
aujourd'hui sur les smartphones android
si vous avez une application instagram
qui va servir à beaucoup de smartphones
différents et qui va pas forcément être
toujours adapté je publiais mais story
avant la qualité vidéo était pas
terrible
là avec ce que propose apple vous avez
une qualité vidéo qui est vraiment
irréprochable une super stabilisation
sauf sur la caméra de celle ci et ça il
faut l'améliorer apple merci beaucoup
voilà pourquoi est-ce que moi en tout
cas je suis vraiment positionné sur ses
smartphones et je trouve vraiment mais
vraiment vraiment très très très bon là
dessus maintenant le tarif je trouve
très élevé il faut vraiment bien
réfléchir avant de l'acheter et si vous
êtes intéressé par ce smartphone là je
vous inviterai attendre quelques jours
de plus pourquoi parce que dans quelques
jours j'aurai l'iphone 12 promax je vais
tester
il ya une différence entre l'iphone 12
pro l'iphone 12 promax en termes de
photos et quelques différences
on y reviendra ensemble justement quand
on parlera de l'iphone 12 promax donc
abonnez vous et restez connectés parce
que c'est quand même dommage qu'un
iphone 12 pro si l'iphone 12 promax
pourrait mieux vous convenir d'ailleurs
dit moi vous dès maintenant ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire moi si
je devais résumer en tout cas mon
rapport à l'iphone je pense que c'est
vraiment un super produit superbe
qualité photo superbe qualité vidéo
extrêmement polyvalent très agréable
pour tous qui va être contenus
multimédias gaming pour regarder des
films des séries vont jouer on a un
smartphone qui répondent très très très
bien qui est beau
qui est résistant je lis pas acheté par
table pour le vérifier mais je crois que
le sans aucun problème et une fois de
plus il faut bien le protéger en tout
cas je suis vraiment convaincu je trouve
très bien est ce que je veux vraiment me
reprocher eh bien c'est la politique
tarifaire par rapport aux accessoires
d'apple ça je voulais dit que je trouve
quand même un peu dommage un peu
dommageable aujourd'hui pour le
consommateur a vous de me dire vous ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
à nous vendre rendez vous extrêmement
rapidement pour continuer parler d'apple
parce qu'il ya plein de choses à dire on
va parler de la paix watch est ce on va
parler des nouveaux ipad d'apple je les
ai tous les deux en test donc on en
reparlera d'ici quelques jours on va
parler bien évidemment de l'iphone 12
appareils de l'iphone 12 pro mac sans
pareil d'iphone 12 min autant vous dire
qu'à plein de choses qui arrivent
apple pas que apple android plein de
trucs tech ça c'est super pour les soins
de bois très vite des gros bisous qu'un
cacao
[Musique]